ecco ho voluto cominciare dal fondo
facendo una storia a ritroso quello che
avete visto è uno dei miei lavori
recenti in cui sono immagine in pratica
si sovrappongono dunque vorrei partire
dalle basi non troppo tecniche ma cos'è
successo negli anni sessanta il cul de
sac della dodecafonia dello
strutturalismo integrale si era un po
arenato nelle possibilità di
comunicazione con il pubblico e ho
suonato molto spesso il pubblico cose
visto causa di molti autori bulles così
e mi rendevo conto e mi sono reso conto
irreversibilmente di una grande
difficoltà da parte del pubblico di
seguire questa musica di capire
attraverso un ascolto cosa accadeva era
la stessa difficoltà che ebbe luigi
dallapiccola famoso compositore prima
generazione e prima che il quando
ascoltò le variazioni di scendere opera
30 uscì dicendo un lavoro magnifico ma
non ho capito nulla dalla piccola sapeva
improvvisare una fuga a quattro voci
quindi evidentemente è nato un problema
molto profondo di realizzazione di una
forma sempre più complessa per un
uditorio sempre meno preparato diciamo
ad ascoltare questo in una società che
piano quando scivolava verso
l'intrattenimento quindi negli anni
sessanta questa crisi profonda si è
manifestata in modo molto forte
soprattutto perché esisteva proprio una
vera e propria scuola di strutturalismo
integrale in germania finanziato dalla
siemens a darmstadt dove praticamente un
neopositivismo si era in qualche modo
fatto portavoce di un pensiero musicale
sempre più profondo sempre più complesso
e questa forma sempre più complessa un
certo punto ha avuto una specie di
collisione
con l'idea della le aleatorietà cioè
dell'idea del caso che qualche modo e
arrivava da john cage dall america
queste due culture si sono fortemente
scontrate e cos'è successo in tutti e
due i casi quello che è venuto a
compromettersi era l'ascolto e perché
nel caso della forma come ripeto c'era
questa difficoltà nel caso del caso del
caso
scusate il bisticcio a questo punto alla
forma si sostituiva all'evento l'evento
era diciamo una cosa improvvisata
atemporale per cui era impossibile che
chi assistesse a questo potesse in
qualche modo decifrare mentre accadeva
ciò che accadeva e in questa situazione
io ho cominciato a studiare molto
profondamente la notazione musicale cara
l'unica cosa che accade che assicura la
durabilità nel tempo delle opere
musicali
quella che vedete non è un mondrian come
potrebbe sembrare
ma è un pezzo di al brava un carro
compositore newyorkese il quale aveva
stabilito con questo con questo lavoro
che si potesse seguire queste questi
elementi attraverso una operazione
esecutiva che diventava approssimativa
se si voleva ma doveva restituire con il
suono questo tipo di criterio spaziale
quindi praticamente il rapporto tra
spazio tempo mutava fondamentalmente un
altro autore loro tethys aveva creato ha
formulato una scrittura musicale di
questo tipo che non era più un codice
cifrato cioè il pentagramma le pause
tutto è vero che serve alla musica per
essere cifrata ma era un intuizione
visiva di ciò che stava per accadere e
questo per esempio lo ha portato perché
è un esempio pratico di una specie di
spettro sonoro per cui l'esecutore
davanti a questo per spettro sonoro
doveva eseguire una spoon a una un'area
una realizzazione fonica sonora di
quello che vedeva quindi a questo punto
questa percezione questo questa
trasformazione richiedeva
una sensibilità e una libertà da una
parte è però era molto esigente
dall'altra perché se un hub un esecutore
non realizzava questo realizzava
improvvisazione e non avrà niente a che
vedere con questo
contemporaneamente sono stato molto
suggestionato in quegli anni da gianni
emilio simonetti che per esempio agli
inizi degli anni sessanta faceva queste
cose che chiamava musica musica muta
voi sapete per esempio thomas mann
doctor faustus fa di reati allevi a un
certo punto che esiste una musica come
il butoh leggere
c'è una musica multa come il butoh
leggere c'era una specie di teoria in
atto in questi anni 60 che portava poi a
quello che è stato successivamente lei
il concettualismo per il quale c'è
sempre da quale teoria a un certo punto
la grafia si autorizzi di si distanziava
dal risultato sonoro e diventava una
cosa a sé davanti al non ascolto davanti
ad una sistema numerologico sempre più
complesso che determinava la forma o una
grafia che in qualche modo rappresentava
lo spettro sonoro se posso dire io avevo
deciso di lavorare sulla grafia
nel frattempo io dipingevo queste cose
quei tempi era la mia attività è la
sfera specificatamente ti pianista però
avevo facevo tutte queste raffigurazioni
diciamo così che eravamo in aspirazione
astratte di certi modi che venivano dall
asp allo studio analitico di singole
figure e suonate al pianoforte nello
nella pratica quotidiana fino a che a un
certo punto ho cominciato a pensare a
delle strutture come questa che sono
strutture di carattere polifonico voi
vedete le strisce praticamente che
attraversano dei campi colorati c'è un
campo celeste
ecco questo tipo di lavoro a un certo
punto per ben diventò una transcodifica
visiva più fatto solo oro per cui chi
non conosceva la musica chi non
conosceva i pentagrammi
sistema cifrato nella notazione poteva
attraverso questi segni avere un'idea
precisa di un evento musicale
ho cominciato a sviluppare a fondo
questo fino a che nel 1972 ho fatto un
ipotesi di teatro musicale a como questo
autunno musicale di piazza un mezzo
musicale in cui una persona alla volta
entrava in uno spazio espositivo e
doveva suonare è talmente queste cose
che gli proponevo queste cose erano
queste immagini che come vedete sono
immagini completamente astratte però
realizzato degli stock rummy che erano
la mia pratica di transcodifica
analogica tra suono e segno ma al tempo
stesso si rifacevano a cacciate
codifiche come quella che ho fattoria di
gioco tethys e erano delle sintesi
grafiche di tutto un sistema di
notazione molto complesso tant'è che
nell 81 feci una mostra intitolata
spartito preso che ha girato diverse
città d'italia per cui ho presentato
varie notazioni di varia natura divise
per funzioni sostanzialmente cercavo un
ponte tra il pubblico e l'ascolto e in
questo modo ho messo in atto l'idea che
era quella che quando la musica scorre
nel tempo perché un'arte temporale che
ascolta riesce a leggere qualche cosa
viene colto da emozioni
a un certo punto entra dentro uno stato
di non consapevolezza della forma anche
perché probabilmente non tutti riescono
ad avere la stessa sensibilità che
catalogati rapporti tra i suoni
c'è chi addirittura non gestite o se un
suono più alto più basso di un altro in
questo modo fissando diciamo per sempre
dando una durabilità a questa immagine
alla musica che scorre nel tempo io
cercavo di realizzare una coscienza
della forma che era la mia esperienza
di lavori che io avevo studiato eseguito
ed i lavori che poi è sulla base di
questa mia esperienza avevo creato come
cose esclusivamente mie diciamo e quindi
ho portato avanti per molti anni questo
tipo di scrittura
voi vedete si è evoluta poi fino a
questo primo per esempio a un pezzo che
poi poteva essere eseguito per voce
perché ero molto impressionato dalle
tavole parolibere di marinetti ho
studiato molto il futurismo perché avrà
era veramente la prima vanguardia che
sintetizzava comparatistica mente varie
arti e al tempo stesso introduceva il
rumore dentro concetto di musica con
luigi russolo con l'app dei rumori si
poteva pensare a qualsiasi rumore
esistente e considerarlo parte di una
composizione musicale tutto questo poi è
stato ripreso da cage i 40 anni dopo
tutto questo ha fatto ha creato una
storia della musica parallela a quella
che poi la scuola dan state tutte le
avanguardie successive e tutte le
avanguardie anche di musica elettronica
che in fondo non erano questo la musica
concreta
era il risultato successivo dell'arte
dei rumori ma avuto pochissimo
pochissimo evoluzione non vi voglio
appesantire su tutte queste cose ma
vogliamo far capire che in questo tipo
di storia
per me la cosa più importante era creare
un ponte di comunicazione e questo ponte
di comunicazione è fissare con una
durata illimitata delle come delle
fotografie delle istantanee sonore e in
questo senso rimando a citazioni cina vi
facciamo potete trovarle facilmente i
famosi fotografi cartier bresson
molti hanno parlato di questo fatto di
fissare nell'istantanea una vita che
scorre in questa istantanea a parte
l'aspetto estetico trovare un diciamo
criterio un criterio proprio formale che
nella vita
tutti i giorni quando viviamo sfugge noi
non abbiamo tutti i giorni come come
potrebbe fare un regista l'inquadratura
non viviamo viviamo inconsapevolmente
però esiste tutti i giorni una nostra
vita che in qualche modo a continua
inquadrature intorno a noi
ecco l'ascolto della musica un po una
cosa simile
in questo modo io volevo farne il
silenzio creare qualche cosa che fosse
anche un carburante per la mente in cui
da queste immagini si potesse in qualche
modo realizzare un pensiero che era un
pensiero di carattere musicale
poi ho cominciato piano piano a fare
anche cose seguivi il pesto per esempio
si chiama grafo di ad è un pezzo per
flauto il fatto dovrebbe riuscire a
suonare questa linea che ascolta vede
questa cosa è la cosa che mi è
interessante che se io faccio un pezzo
più il flauto scritto innovazione
tradizionale e lo faccio ascoltare le
persone lo ascoltano ma non hanno una
coscienza di questa linea
ascoltando qualche cosa che non è come
dire percepibile perché l'orecchio è
molto meno abile dell'occhio l'occhio è
molto abile mettendo insieme le due cose
si crea una nuova sintassi per la quale
sia una nuova percezione proprio della
musica qui si aprirebbe un discorso
sull'emozione sull'emotività su quello
che è l'aspetto espressivo della musica
ma lì il discorso è molto lungo perché
consonanza dissonanza ritmi geometrici
ritmi astratti ritmi asimmetrici e tutto
quello di tattica e costituisce la forma
della musica ha avuto delle peripezie
delle esplosioni delle reintegrazioni
delle cause per cui a un continuo over
si sarebbe molto lungo
analizzare la portata semantica di tanta
musica partendo da delle forme così
diverse non c'è un omologazione della
forma più difficilissima verona
omologazione della sostanza lo è
difficile per beethoven
direi che è impossibile oggi solamente
che oggi c'è un uso per la musica che
qualche modo
e già tutto il passato o diciamo
soprattutto dell'evoluzione del
linguaggio e romantico ma crea un grande
caos per cui come se si facesse delle
continue gastronomie in cui si mettono
insieme degli elementi e il pubblico può
riconoscere a volte il sapore del
prezzemolo fa per un caso però perde
completamente il senso di quello che sta
di quello di cui si sta occupando
insomma ecco questo per esempio un pezzo
nerio scrissi per pianoforte
negli anni 70 avrei dovuto e pensavo che
potesse suonato il pubblico e lo feci
perché in una piazza di prato mesi un
pianoforte e le persone potevano tentare
un esecuzione pianistica perché per me
era molto importante la un'esperienza
diretta di fare suono tutte queste cose
sono vissute diciamo negli anni 70 80 90
se avete visto come sono finito quello
che ho fatto era il successivo passo non
più l'analogia tra un certo tipo di
segni ha un certo tipo di suono e un
certo colore e una certa timbrica ma la
giusta posizione delle due cose
quindi posso farvi vedere ancora questi
sono tutti tutte raffigurazioni che io
chiamavo annotazioni più fatto sonoro
che l'esecutore il pubblico ricrea nella
propria immaginazione
qui ti chiederei meditazione su ogni
singolo su ogni singola immagine
naturalmente adesso quelle falso sta
finendo il tempo per cui per le passò
velocemente però per chiudere per me la
durabilità è la sensazione di una forma
che è concepita che capita e che in
qualche modo è riconoscibile come si fa
un ma lo dia e orecchiabile perché è
riconoscibile la possibilità che nella
forma ci sia un vecchio una
orecchiabilità nel senso che si possa
riconoscere cosa succede
questo è anche un altro pezzo per voce
dove c'è anche un testo sia in questo è
un altro pezzo più voce mi sono occupato
molto dei labirinti come disorientamento
e sono ritornato qua delle scritture
abbastanza tradizionali facendo tutta
una serie di labili
i giochi vedete in cui l'esecutore entra
molti sono molo viari africa sono invece
della biglietti diversi questo per
esempio è un labirinto che poi ho fatto
per di 8 metri per 8 in cui il flautista
cammina su una partitura viene riflesso
da una telecamera che spara questa cosa
in una parete e pubblico riesce in
qualche modo a seguire questo questo
questo percorso
ecco vi ringrazio tempo finita